[Müzik]
Merhabalar bugün bu sahnede anlatacağım
şeylerin hiçbirini yayında anlatmıyorum
Aslında bakarsanız tedx konuşmalarına
biraz mesafeliydim ama dediler ki bu bir
kadın seçkisi ve konumuz da yeniden
tanımlama dedim ki şimdi ortam ortama
benzedi neşemiz yerine geldi Kaliteye
Hoş geldiniz doğru adrestesiniz çünkü bu
yeniden tanımlama meselesi ile ilgili
benim biraz dertlerim var aslında
inceden inceye bir kendini methetme
seansı olarak da görürdüm böyle
konuşmaları fakat hiç merak etmeyin
bugün buraya kendimi övmeye değil
gömmeye geldim
Ben bir haberci ve sunucuyum ve 17
yaşından beri hayatımı soru sorarak
yazarak konuşarak yani anlatarak
kazanıyorum yine de biri bana Kendi
hikayeni anlat Duygu dediğinde bundan
çok
utanıyorum yayınlarda ya da sahnelerde
Devlet Ana gibiyim Ama mesela şu an şu
sahnedeki varlığın bir rahatsız
ediyorsam ben kalkayım biçiminde Çünkü
bu ülke bu iklim bu toplum Bana kendi
hikayemin anlatılmaya değer olduğunu hiç
hissettirmemiş mikrofonu büyük olanlara
bakıyorum kendini anlatmayı iştahla
seviyorlar Ben onlardan biri olamadım
ama anlatmaya değer başka şeyler buldum
hayat mücadelesi verenler ve bu
mücadeleyi onurla iyilikle verenler
muhabir olarak çalışmaya başladığında
İstanbul'u hiç tanımadığım için biraz
şehri öğreneyim biraz da yol yordam
öğreneyim diye beni sürekli eylemlere
gönderdiler
Hatta müdürlerimin tarifi ile bir kız
çocuğunun gitmemesi gereken her yere
gittim sınır hattı Savaş bölgeleri
sınırın Ötesi facia Sahaları afet
Sahaları hastaneler Karakollar Emniyet
Genel Müdürlüğü adli tıp morg çok
Sonraları müdürlerim arasında bir bahis
konusu olduğumu öğrendim çünkü beni bir
sonraki işe gönderdiklerinde aralarında
şöyle diyorlarmış bu Herhalde fazla
yaşamaz bu gitti de geri gelmez ya da bu
artık buna da ben gitmeyeyim abi der
çünkü her seferinde çıtayı birazcık
yükseltiyorlardı diyelim irticacı bir
örgütü mensupları cezaevinden tahliye
olmuş adamların son faaliyeti İçeri
girmeden önce domuz bağı bana diyorlardı
ki Duygu bir git bak bakalım ne
yapacaklar bundan sonra kariyer
Planlarında ne var bir röportaj yap
bakalım ya gitmeyeyim abi deme seçeneği
varmış O hiç aklıma gelmiyordu eylemleri
seviyordum ama eylemler kolay değildi
protestolar Kolay değildi çünkü bazen
ben kameraman kestane satan sivil polis
dahil olmak üzere eylemde 6 kişi
oluyoruz yani eylemci kendi duyurduğu
eyleme gelmiyor Nasıl olsa Duygu
geliyordur diye bütün bu dertleri yine
de canlı yayında insanlara anlatmak
istiyordum Bunun için ama editörleri
ikna etmeniz lazım Çünkü bir ulusal
kanalda bir haber kanalında bir
dakikalık bir yayın bile çok kıymetliydi
o zamanlar ve editör size şöyle söyler
rejide çalışan arkadaşlar Duygu Bak
orası kalabalıksa Alacağım seksiyse
alacağım renkli ise alacağım çok renkli
8 kişiyiz birbirinden renkli 8 kişiyiz
orada ama
İş kazalarında evlatlarını kaybetmiş 8
kişiyiz ya da bir dakika bir yayında
derdini anlatmak için tam 45 dakika
yağmurun altında bekleyen 8 kişiyiz
sonunda Onun da formülünü buldum
kameramandan açıyı daraltmasını istedim
eylemcilere ablacığım biraz
sıkışabilirsek dedim Bir de genelde de
biliyorsunuz böyle bir kepçe iş makinesi
çalıştığında seyretmeyi çok sevenler
olur ya beni de seyretmeyi sevenler hep
oluyordu genelde sahada onlara da sayın
abim Siz de arkaları takviye ederseniz
dedim ve yani hiç alakaları olmayan
eylemlerde binlerce kişiyi buluşturmayı
başardım bunların yayınını yapmayı da
başardım çok önemsiyordum ve çok
seviyordum yaptığım işi ta ki O gün
gelene kadar
bir gün biri bana dedi ki bildiğin Her
şeyi unut Duygu Kendini yeniden tanımla
Üstelik öyle biri dedi ki çalıştığım
televizyon kanalının bağlı bulunduğu
medya grubu bir şirketten Başka bir
şirkete satıldı Ama öyle kolay bir Geçiş
olmadı bu emevilerden abbasilere geçti
gibi düşünün
kanlı bir geçiş oldu ve yüzlerce
gazeteci işini kaybetti Ben de onlardan
biriydim Üstelik o sırada kanalın ana
haberini sunduğum için ilk sıradaydım
Çünkü herkes o koltuğu merak ediyor ve
herkes o koltuk için iştahlanıyor
Dolayısıyla kimin yerimize geleceğine
dair listeler çok önceden hazırlanmıştır
bunu tebliğ etmek için yeni yöneticiler
belirlediler ve bir gün bir yayın
sonrası
benim ne kadar iyi bir insan olduğumu ve
ne kadar iyi bir haberci olduğumu
söyleyerek beni kovan yeni yönetici o
konuşmada öyle bir ağladı ki ama öyle
bir ağladı ki sonunda dedim ki yapma
geçecek atlatacaksın bunu Bak benim
işsizlik maaşım bağlansın İlk sana
göndereceğim tahmin edebileceğiniz bir
samimiyet düzeyinde geçti o fakat
konuşmanın sonunda odadan Çıkmadan bana
dedi ki ya Duygum acaba bundan sonra
hani çok iyi habercisin falan ama o
kadar da şey yapmasan mı Hani yeniden
tanımla demiyor ama ne yapmazsam bu ne
bileyim diyor Sen mesela diyor hani
ahlaksız ahlaksız diyorsun Halbuki insan
ahlaksız olduğunu biliyor yani o kadar
doğrudan söylemesen de biraz ortadan mı
gitsem bildiğin her şeyi unutsan mı
Halbuki bildiğim şey çok kıymetliydi
benim ya
Kendi hikayeni başkalarının hikayesinden
büyük sayma doğruyu söyle az kazanma
pahasına çok çalışma pahasına işsiz
kalma Hedef olma pahasına
Bu yeniden tanımlama meselesini bir kere
daha duyduğumda işsizliğimin 4 ayıydı
evde mutfağın musluğu bozulmuştu ben de
watt kalıcak etlerim Bütün arkadaşlarıma
dağıttığım için mecburen eşofmanla
oturuyordum yoksa Normalde evde de
böyleyim
tamirci geldi tamirata başladı ve hani
böyle kimsenin sizi tanımayacağından
emin olduğunuz ve Bunu istediğiniz anlar
vardır ya öyle bir an yaşıyordum bende
fakat abi tezgahın altından çıktı ve
bana şöyle söyledi
Biz o kanalda iyiydiniz aslında ya neden
bıraktınız dedi
abi bırakmadım Kovuldum Ben dedim
o zaman dedi
geri dedim günün sonunda da musluğu
yapamadı biliyor musunuz fakat evden
ayrılırken bana şunu söyledi yani
televizyonu Bırak zaten kim izliyor
televizyonu dedi sen dijitale geç asıl
hararet orada orada hareketli bir şeyler
yap dedi
Amin maalesef onu çok sevdiğim bir sözü
var der ki bizler istikbalin birer
taslığıydı fakat İstikbal taslak olarak
kalmaya devam edecekti o an ben sektör
temsilcileri için yöneticiler için
medyacılar ve muslukçular için geleceğin
parlak bir taslağıydım fakat bir şartla
kendimi yeniden tanımlamayı
başarabilirsem
bu işe çok kafam basmadığı için önce
mevcut tanımımı anlamaya çalıştım benim
doğup büyüdüğüm yerde yani medyada
kadınlar çok yaşamaz kadın ömrü kısadır
çünkü sizin haberleri ya da herhangi bir
şeyi erkekten dinlemeyi daha çok
sevdiğinize dair bazı araştırmalar var
şimdi bir hızlı anket yapacağız Aranızda
ben hakikaten haberleri bir erkekten
dinlediğimde daha ikna oluyorum
diyenleri bir duyabilir miyim var mı
Onlar
sahnede herhangi Birinizin yüzünü
göremiyorum eşgal belirleyemem rahat
olsun
tekrar soruyorum aranızda erkekten
dinliyorum daha çok seviyorum bu işi
diyenler alkışlayabilir mi
enteresan o Medeni cesaret sahibi
beyefendi kutluyorum bu Tek alkışın
Sahibi Peki aranızda erkeklerin kendi
cinsel performansları ile ilgili nasıl
kolay yalan söyleyebildiklerini bilenler
var mı Onlar bir alkışlayabilir
[Alkış]
şimdi Sevgili dostlar bu adamın size
haberi mutlaka doğru anlattığına dair
düşünce Sizde nasıl oluştu da beni
harcadınız
durun böyle gerçekten
[Alkış]
Bu arada evliler alkışlamayaydı iyiydi
buna değmez Ben şimdi tezimi kanıtlamak
için bir başka örnek vereceğim çünkü
size çalıştığım platformda yayınlarımızı
duyurmak için şehirlere afişler
bilboardlar asıldı çok havalı afişler
Bunlar afişin bir tarafında
ellilerinin ortasında son derece
itibarlı son derece iyi Görünen bir
erkek haberci var diğer tarafında
30'larının başında son derece itibarıyla
son derece iyi Görünen bir kadın haberci
var o ben oluyorum Çok hoşuma gitti afiş
tabii ama afişi Gözün bir yerden
ısırıyor nereden biliyorum Nereden
biliyorum buldum 20 yıl önceden
biliyorum o işi çünkü 20 yıl önce aynı
erkek enker o afişin içindeydi 30larının
ortasında son derece iyi görünen son
derece itibarlı bir erkek haberci ve
yanında 30larının ortasında son derece
iyi görünen son derece itibarlı bir
kadın haberci
yani aradan geçen 20 yıl O afişten
sadece kadını çıkardı
şimdi aradan bir 20 yıl daha geçecek
Sevgili dostlarım afişi bir daha
sıcaklar
70lerinin ortasında son derece iyi
görünen son derece itibarlı bir erkek
haberci ve Eğer yanındaki 30larının
ortasında bir kadın haberci ise bizim
Bunun hesabını alayınıza sormamız lazım
Çünkü iddia ediyorlar ki bunu siz
istiyorsunuz
Sevgili dostlar erkeğin bu sahneye
çıkması yetiyor benim sizi ikna etmem
için bile suyun üzerinde yürümem lazım
yani benim aynı anda size
Ukrayna krizinin Avrupa'daki enerji dar
boğazını ülkedeki Cumhurbaşkanı aday
adaylarında Türkiye'deki enflasyonu
İngiltere'deki resesyonu İran'daki kadın
hakları mücadelesini Çin'in yeni
yapılanmasını anlatırken bütün bunlara
hakim olurken Bir de afişte duracak
kadar iyi görünmem lazım
ama erkek nefes alsa yetiyor
ve şöyle düşünün bu kadınlara ait olduğu
söylenen tek şeydi onu da kaptırmışız
harika yani mevcut durum bizim yüzümüzü
Hiçbir şekilde güldürmüyor ben bunu
anladım dedim ki o zaman Ben muslukçu
abinin dediğini dinleyeyim dijitale
geçeyim dijitalde bir şeyler yapayım
orada da şununla karşılaştım
dediler ki Duygu Senin bir şeyin olsun
seni bir şeyle bilelim ne bileyim işte
öfkenle atarınla küfrünle delilin ne
duygusallığında yayında böyle bir şey
yap bize bir şey sat bize bu arada bunu
bana gerçekten de söylediler bize bir
şey sat bir konuyu sahiplen mesela
dediler En milliyetçi sen ol gençlere en
çok sen sahiplen ben dedim ki ya bu
kadın meseleleri benim ilgimi çekiyor
aslında da yok yok o kapıldı dediler
böyle ürünler var Ve bunu size tavsiye
edenler bunu Size anlatanlar yemin
ederim sabah kalktıklarında aynaya
baktıklarında o insanı kendileri de
görmüyorlar Ben bunu reddettim
çünkü icraatından büyük tabelası olan
herkesten çok korkuyorum Çünkü
hikayemi sizin hikayenizden büyük Sayan
anlayışı reddediyorum ve size bir şey
anlatmak için daha Absürt daha şok edici
daha vahşi daha rezil Olmam gerektiği
fikrinden kaçıyorum bu beni çok
korkutuyor çünkü Bence hepimiz dünyada
yeteri kadar Rezalet gördük mesela
politikacılar yeterince çaldı bizden
yeterince Yalan Söylediler ya da ülkenin
büyük facialarında yeterince insanımızı
kaybettik bir noktada o rezaletlerin
hepsine yeter dememiz gerekiyordu Ve
bunu size yapmak istemedim bugünkü
konuşmayı da o yüzden böyle dürüst bir
konuşma olarak planladım Aslında
bakarsanız başlamadan önce Kafamın
içinde Aristo Platon ve ben oturduk ve
bugün karşınıza çıkabileceğim güzellikte
bir konuşma yazdık
İnşallah bir gün o konuşmayı da dinleme
şansınız olur Çünkü adamlar gittikten
sonra ben kendi bildiğim konuşmayı
yazdım şunu düşünüyorum
belki de kendimizi yeniden tanımlamaya
ihtiyacımız yoktur ama bu şuna mutlaka
ihtiyacımız var
hepimiz umudu koyacak hayali koyacak bir
yer arıyoruz Kahraman arıyoruz
Bu da çok Anlaşılır bir şey bit genişten
bir sözünde diyor ki düsturumuz şu olsun
büyülenmeyelim
Sevgili dostlarım ben büyülenmeyi
bıraktım bir süredir
Eğer bir şeyi yeniden tanımlayacaksanız
naçizane tavsiyem lütfen Kahraman
listenizi alın önünüze ve o Listenin
başına kendi Adınızı yazın
hayatımın kadını benim
kahramanım kim benim
Annem Merhaba anne Az önce cinsel Espri
yaptım diye kızdın mı
biraz konuşmanın son halini
göndermediğim için sinirliydi şu anda
daha da sinirli Yapacak bir şey yok
hayatımın kadını 20 yıldır nasıl Şahane
Bir Kadın olduğuna Tanık olduğumu en
yakın kız arkadaşım bugün burada yanımda
olan ofiste nasıl çalıştığına şahit
olduğum emek veren en yakın dostum Çünkü
ben bu kahramanları Biliyorum bana bir
şey satmak istemediklerini de biliyorum
benim gibi olduklarını da biliyorum bir
süredir evime paketli gıda almıyorum ve
paketlenmiş kahramanları kapımdan içeri
sokmuyorum Çünkü ambalajına o kadar
mesai harcanan bir şeyin içinden mutlaka
bir hinlik çıkacağını Biliyorum belki de
yeniden tanımlamaya ihtiyacımız yoktur
kendimize ama bunu mutlaka yapmanızı
istiyorlarsa lütfen kendinize şunu sorun
bu yeni tanım yeni tarif bana mı ait Ben
sadece Gerçekten bunu istiyor muyum
eğer biz bunu yapmazsak ne olacak onu
anlatayım birleşmiş milletlerin son
raporuna göre dünyada kadın ve erkeğin
eşit şartlara sahip olması için kaç yıl
var hızlı anket 10 yılla açıyorum Alkışı
duyayım
güzel 50 fena değil 100
Maşallah muhteşem pozitif bir kitle
normalde de görüşelim normal hayatta da
ama haklısınız bilmekten ileri geliyor
bu sessizlik kadın ve erkeğin eşit
şartlara sahip olması için 286 yıl var
önümüzde Yani güya ben sahnedeyim ya
sahnedeki ben ve en arka koltukta oturan
buraya da biraz Mecburiyetten gelmiş
erkek arkadaşımın ya da erkek
izleyicinin benimle eşit şartlara sahip
olması için 3 Asır geçmesi gerekiyor
kadın lehine geçmesi gerekiyor Bu üç
Asırın üç kere Reyhan Ne olsam yine eşit
şartlara sahip olamıyorum Dolayısıyla bu
tanımı biz yapacağız yaparken ne ile
karşılaşacağız derseniz dirençle ve
tepkiyle karşılaşacaksınız kolay bir şey
değil kendini tarif etmek bugün İran'da
mahzamininin ardından başlayan
protestolarda kadınlar bunu yaşıyor
Taliban rejiminin altında hayatta
kalmaya çalışan kız çocukları bunu
yaşıyor Düşünsenize kendisini yeniden
tanımlama cesaretini
küçücük kız çocukları gösteriyor O
videoyu size izletemiyorum Ama
taliban'da bir üniversite kampüsünün
önünde onlarca genç kadın okullarına
girmek istiyorlar Kapının önünde de bir
tane Taliban üyesi çok daha cesaret
sahibi Çünkü elinde çok büyük bir kırbaç
var kapıya doğru şöyle benim attığım
gibi bir adım atan kızların Yüzüne
kırbaçla Vuruyor onlarca kızın Yüzüne
kırbaçla Vuruyor Şimdi size soruyorum
Yarın sabah işe gideceksiniz okula
gideceksiniz bakkala gideceksiniz
gittiğiniz kapının önünde kırbaçlanıyor
olsaydınız hanginizde ertesi gün oraya
bir daha gidecek cesaret vardı ama o
kadınlar gidiyorlar Çünkü bu tarifin bu
yaşam hakkının Kendilerine ait olduğunu
biliyorlar ikinci bir şey daha
yapıyorlar dayanışıyorlar tek başlarına
gitmiyorlar hep birlikte gidiyorlar bunu
hep birlikte yapmak zorundayız
hayatımızda
Yoksa ne olacak derseniz yoksa şunu
söyleyeyim
benim konuşmamın başı ve sonu arasında
iki kadın öldürülecek
hiç kaçarı yok bunun istatistik bunu
söylüyor bize 11 dakika dünyada her 11
dakikada bir kadın tanıdığı biri
tarafından öldürülüyor
trafik kazası Geçirmiyor Bu kadınlar
kalp krizi Geçirmiyor ama katilleriyle
bir ömür geçirenler var aralarında
Türkiye'deki kadın cinayetleri
davalarının gerekçeli kararlarına bakın
Hani işkence ile bir kadın öldürdükten
sonra
bedenini bir varile koyup yakan katille
ilgili mahkemenin verdiği şu karar
cesedi yakması canavarca hisle suç
işlediği anlamına gelmez olsa olsa olsa
cesedi yok etmek istemiştir kıyamam
deyip Haksız tahrik indirimi veren o
kararları okuyun sonra o kararların
haber olduğu sitelerin Altındaki
yorumları okuyun o kadınlarla ilgili
neler yazmışlar Yarın hepiniz onu
yazanlarla aynı otobüstesiniz aynı
sokakta yürüyeceksiniz hiçbir yabancınız
değil ya da öldürülen kadınların ismini
internete yazdıktan sonra hani böyle
takip eden kelimeler oluyor ya Bunu mu
demek istediniz bunu mu aratıyorsunuz
diye bakın bakalım bir boşluk
bıraktıktan sonra ne diyorlar O
kadınlarla ilgili
evli miymiş O adam onun sevgilisi miymiş
O gece o saatte ne işi varmış fotoğrafı
neymiş bacak
yakılarak öldürülen kadınla ilgili bacak
araması yapanlar var Şimdi bana
diyeceksin ki İyi de duygu bu Kadınlar
kendilerini yeniden tanımlamadıkları
için mi öldürüldüler Hayır
Bu kadınlar onları başkaları tanımladığı
için bu hadsizliği bu cüreti
gösterdikleri o cesareti buldukları için
cezasız kaldıkları için öldürüldüler
Bizler bize yapıştırılan etiketler
yüzünden öldürülüyor
TED ile başladım konuşmaya TED ile
bitireyim biliyorsunuz format şu bu
Dairenin içinde kalmam gerekiyor
kameranın beni rahatlıkla takip
edebilmesi için fakat içinde durduğum bu
çember bu daire
bana çizilen çembere çok benziyor benim
hayatıma kariyerime çok benziyor Bence
sizinkine de çok benziyor
başkaları tarafından belirlenen
sınırların içinde durur
Üstelik o kadar muntazamdır o kadar
güzel Dur ki bu sınırı sana başkalarının
çizdiğini kimseye hatırlatma Kendine
bile çaktırma
şimdi bu akşam bu şenlik dağılacak
hepimiz sokağa çıkacağız
hayatlarımızda yeni etiketler yeni
haftalar yeni tanımlar olacak kolay mı
hepsinden sıyrılmak kolay mı kendini
tarif etmek yeniden tanımlamak değil
elbette ama zor işleri kimler yapmalı
yapabilenler bu durumda Kadınlar nasıl
yapmalı dayanışmayla kendinizi her zaman
yeniden tanımlamak zorunda falan
değilsiniz Ama olduğunuz insanı seçmek
zorundasınız
kendinizi seçmek zorundasınız
kendinizi seçmek zorundasınız çünkü Eğer
siz bunu yapmazsanız sıradaki 11 dakika
Belki sizi öldürmeyecek fakat yaşıyor da
sayılmayacaksınız teşekkür ederim